it's number five cybersecurity this time
last year computer virus known as
heartbleed tore through corporate
servers across the nation the hole in
data protection gave hackers the ability
to steal secret key is used to encrypt
usernames passwords and other
information at the time some half a
million of the Internet secure web
servers were believed to be vulnerable
to attack however one year later and it
appears seventy-four percent of global
companies haven't fixed their servers
and networks and joining me or still
with me to discuss as activate founder
michael wolf activate as a strategy and
technology consulting firm and we don't
hear as much about there's not as much
of the headlines about heartbleed but
it's still out there it wasn't the
apocalypse that everybody expected but
still a lot of companies haven't
addressed it but the bigger issue is you
now have to expect that everybody has
been hacked or is going to be hacked
it's not just think about list last year
Home Depot target chase anthem olive and
of course most notably Sony they've all
been hacked so it's no longer just a
tech problem it's now one that companies
have to be dealing with every single day
well I would imagine I mean certainly at
those companies but I would imagine that
all big companies that rely on big data
networks the CEO is directly getting
involved in security the CEO is looking
this at looking at this as a big risk
issue and now also we have networks in
which the IT professionals can get
together so Facebook just started a
network of for IT professionals to be
able to exchange information on a
real-time basis but overall we don't
know how to fight a cyber war so for
example even though the white hat the
White House has just set up an office
for cyber security in the same way that
they set up an office for the war on
terrorism it's just not the same thing
that well that's what they do right they
create a new bureaucracy whenever we
have a big problem is this bureaucracy
going to help corporations are we going
to see the NSA the CIA stepping in to
help out the Sony's or the targets of
the world well in some ways people are
worried about the NSA I mean the you
it's it's thought from the documents
that Edward Snowden released that both
the UK and the US
governments have already hacked into the
sim card database so on so this is going
to be much more about companies working
together to solve the problem then it's
going to be about the government or it's
going to be about regulation but expect
once again that you're going to find you
have to know that one way the other your
system has been compromised does this
hurt cloud services that have become so
big and important I mean are we going to
see a turnaround where people want to
take their data out of the cloud and
hold it on their own save Smart Watch or
on their own servers at home I mean the
the challenge is as long as you're some
way connected to the outside then you
face the same risk you're a cloud is no
different in terms of risk than a server
that's in your office and in fact the
cloud providers can do a much better job
of moving very quickly on resolving the
challenges versus somebody in their
office or at home I guess I have to get
one of those Tesla home batteries using
analog landline and only cash for
transactions yeah exactly but but more
importantly you give up the Internet
yeah if you're if you're that worried